Hey fam. So, it is time for a good
old-fashioned walk and talk because uh
your boy Drex has got some thoughts
about identity and he wants to share
them with you today.
[music]
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, we are talking
a little bit about how identity comes
into how we deal with the outside world.
But before we dive in, I just want to
give a quick shout out to the friends of
the channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys,
Pyroer, Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this here video. So,
let's talk for a second about who we are
versus how we are seen. Cuz there's
always going to be a gap between those
two things. Other people experience us
not as a constant series of moments like
we do inhabiting our own heads, but as
an intermittent presence.
You know, they they may get a selection
of those moments that add up to a
picture that is pretty different than
what we perceive in our own minds, or
the events that they perceive might wind
up aligning quite closely with how we
see ourselves. It kind of depends. The
thing is though is that we we we can't
really control the moments that others
receive of us. We can't control when
they're watching and when they're not.
And yet so many of us define ourselves
and our self-worth according to the
perceptions of those who are viewing us
from afar. And the thing about doing
that is
only we ourselves actually have the full
picture. See, I think that a lot of us
look at the reception that we receive
from our friends and people in our
community as kind of like a barometer as
to whether we're good people, how worthy
we are, or even like what our sense of
self-image should be.
But like by definition,
when we give that power away to others,
it also means that we're robbing
ourselves of the agency of true
self-nowledge. If we can trust others to
ascribe our value, but we can't trust
ourselves,
not only have we placed one of the most
important facets of our relationship
with ourselves in the hands of people
who are working with very incomplete
data,
we're also kind of saying in effect that
we don't trust ourselves. Relying on
perceptions of ourselves to guide our
sense of worth, self, and value places
us in a position where we're always
working to prove ourselves to our
friends, to our family, to complete
strangers. And in many cases, it's to
people who've decided who we are already
based upon their own prejudices rather
than who we actually are. So, here's the
really, really, really important part of
this to kind of receive and absorb, and
that's that it seems like when we're
seeking that acceptance, part of what
we're also seeking is an impact or even
healing, a feeling of belonging. But the
problem is it's actually a recipe for
shame and disappointment and
frustration.
Because as painful as it is, we will
never be seen as we see ourselves.
because
that's just not in our control. But do
you know what is in our control?
We can learn to trust ourselves.
We can recognize that only we are
present for our entire lives. We can
recognize that if we can't trust, love,
and respect ourselves that there's no
amount of external perception that's
going to change that. Seeking it leads
to an endless cycle of prostrating
ourselves before the fickle temperaments
of others and not infrequently
sacrificing parts of our own happiness
in order to win the approval of others.
Because seeking that approval in the
first place is a statement that the
approval of others is more important
than anything we already have within us,
including our own happiness. And
granted, sometimes that relationship
with ourselves is pretty complicated.
Sometimes having access to all of the
moments of our life feels like a curse
in and of itself because so many of
those moments are things that we feel
ashamed of and we're kind of grateful
that only we are privy to them. And the
approval of others represents an escape.
Like it it becomes a character that we
can play that is everything that we fear
we are not. confident, sexy, smart,
popular, humble, talented, or even wise.
But like, [laughter]
I've played a version of that character
many times in my life. I've believed if
only I can get other people to believe
that this is who I am, maybe I can
believe it myself.
But the psychological strain of trying
to inhabit that character, of being the
perfect version of this person that I
wished to be wore away at me. It added
to my shame rather than reducing it
because as I had access to all my
moments,
I was really abundantly aware of just
how big a lie the character I was
playing actually was. Cuz like here's
the thing. The personas that we create
to win approval,
they aren't actually escapes
over time. They become prisons.
People may seem to love and respect us,
but not for who we are, but for who we
pretend to be in order to earn their
approval.
And as a result, we sit in fear the day
when they discover who we actually are.
And because we're ashamed of that
person, we assume that they're going to
be too. Like real talk, none of us are
perfect. We just have to accept that. As
my therapist reminded me during a
discussion of the film Conclave, even
the Pope sins. I don't think that it's
healthy to make our job winning the
approval of others. I think that we need
to win the approval of ourselves.
to look at the sum of the moments that
we and only we are privy to and
recognize that even in those moments of
selfishness and pettiness, of weakness,
wrath, self-doubt, greed, condescension,
and so many more that we are actually
still worthy of love from ourselves of
from nobody else. Look, straight up, we
all make mistakes and we all do things
that we regret.
Accept them.
Judging yourself for them means that
you'll also judge others for them and
the cycle will just continue. But
seriously, above all else,
please learn to trust yourself. Learn to
accept yourself.
Asking other people to do it for you
isn't just dangerous.
It almost never works out in the end.
So,
that was intense. Um, I hope you got
something out of this. Uh, if you did,
please make sure to like, comment,
share, and subscribe to help other
people find this video and hopefully
help my channel grow.
[music]
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my FL patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
so much for [music] your support. And if
you out there watching uh would like to
say get your name in the credits or
access to a host of a whole bunch of
other awesome rewards, you can get
access to those by going and signing up
for my Patreon [music] over at
patreon.com/drexfactorploy.
I'll leave a link to it down in the
description as well as up in [music] the
cards. And if you would like to see a
series of other vlogs I've done on
various topics related to mental health,
I'll go ahead and include a link to a
playlist of those videos up on screen so
you can check [music] them out for
yourself. Thank you so much for joining
me today. Thank you for watching and
I'll see you with a new video real soon.
[music]
Peace.